lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar paso a paso el programa que
escribimos en el vídeo anterior para
entender lo que realmente pasa línea por
línea y podremos entender mejor cómo
funciona el ciclo for y las variables y
lo haremos con un ejemplo específico un
ejemplo en el que mediante el prompt el
usuario teclea el valor del número del
que quiere calcular el factorial y
asumiremos que el usuario teclea el
número 3 y usaremos un número pequeño
para evitar que el ciclo fort se ejecute
para siempre y para que este vídeo sea
de una duración razonable y cuando el
usuario teclea el número 3 el programa
asigna a la variable número el 3 y
existen dos maneras en que podemos
visualizar esto una manera es ver las
variables como contenedores siempre
tenemos la tendencia a ver las variables
como contenedores aquí tengo el
contenedor llamado número y cuando el
usuario teclea en 3 podemos pensar que
en este contenedor tenemos el número 3
payton es un poco diferente de otros
lenguajes y la manera más correcta de
las variables en python considerando que
las dos maneras son intuitivas es pensar
que apuntan a un valor que se refiere al
3 y digo esto porque si en python
cambiamos el valor de una variable por
ejemplo si hacemos número igual a 2 no
hicimos esto en el programa pero digamos
que el número es igual a 2
payton deja en 3 en la memoria y hace
que la variable número apunte a 2 que
haga referencia a este 2 no es que borre
el 3 y ponga un 2 el 3 sigue en la
memoria y es importante entender esto
porque empezaremos a hacer cosas padres
con diferentes tipos de datos pero
déjenme quitar todo esto para el
objetivo de este programa podemos ver
las variables como contenedores con un 3
o como una etiqueta que apunta al 3 en
algún lugar de la memoria de la
computadora ahora lo siguiente es que
tenemos otra variable llamada producto y
asignamos a la variable producto el
valor 1 así que déjenme hacer las dos
representaciones ponemos otro
tenedora aquí llamado producto y le
asignamos el valor 1 ponemos un 1 en
este contenedor o podemos decir que el
producto es una variable es una etiqueta
que hace referencia a uno y luego
entramos al ciclo for que es
probablemente la parte confusa de este
programa
fort y en range de número
el intérprete dice ok que es número y en
este ejemplo número es literalmente 3
así que esto va a ser evaluado como
range de 3 en este ejemplo particular
french de 3 otra vez como sabe el
intérprete esto porque dice range de
número número es una variable busca el
valor de la variable número que es 3 y
lo pone aquí range de 3 o busque el
valor de la variable y esta variable
apunta al número 3
así que pone el 3 aquí y hace range de 3
y vimos en el vídeo anterior que si
evaluamos solo range de 333 es igual a
la secuencia de números
012 así que crea una secuencia de tres
números empezando por cero y hasta el
número menos uno y lo que el ciclo for
hace es cada vez que entre en el ciclo
ejecuta este código que está dentro del
ciclo fort y sabemos que está dentro de
este ciclo porque lo intentamos la
convención más usada en python es no
usar la tecla tap sino usar cuatro
espacios y eso le dice al intérprete de
payton que todo lo que está escrito en
ese nivel de ventas jon se debe ejecutar
cada vez que pasa por el ciclo for y
cuando entramos en el ciclo for
la variable y se hace igual a cero así
que la primera vez que entramos en el
ciclo four y será 0 el primer elemento
de esta secuencia la siguiente vez que
entramos en el ciclo y será igual al
segundo elemento de la secuencia y
cuando vamos al ciclo for una vez más la
variable y será igual al tercer elemento
de la secuencia y luego entramos en el
ciclo for una vez más y se tratará de
asignar ahí
el elemento de la secuencia pero
entonces dirá si no hay más elementos en
la secuencia entonces terminan el ciclo
y continuará con el resto del programa
así que sabiendo esto veamos qué pasa en
este ejemplo particular en el que el
usuario teclea el número 3
entonces range de número será evaluado
como vemos aquí 0 1 2 y la primera vez
en el ciclo y apuntará a este 0
o si consideramos las variables como en
este lado tendremos un contenedor y con
el primer elemento de range de 3 el
primer elemento de la secuencia que es 0
y luego se ejecuta lo que está dentro
del ciclo asignamos un valor nuevo a
producto le asignamos el valor de
producto y cuál será ese nuevo valor la
primera vez que entramos en el ciclo el
valor de iu es 0 + 1 es 1 así que la
primera vez que entramos en el ciclo
este será 10 + 1 producto es 1 la
primera vez que entramos en el ciclo así
que y es 0 + 1 es 1 producto es uno por
uno el nuevo valor que asignaremos al
producto es uno por uno el valor que
reasignar hemos al producto es 1 aunque
en realidad no cambia porque
anteriormente era 1
era uno y lo multiplicamos por uno y
sigue siendo uno lo voy a poner aquí
puedo cruzar este uno y será uno otra
vez pero voy a dejar este uno o podemos
decir se reasignará a uno en realidad
nada cambio después de pasar la primera
vez por este ciclo pero ahora vamos a
ver que pasan cosas interesantes ahora
volvemos al principio del ciclo y ahora
ahí será el siguiente elemento en el
ciclo déjenme borrar esto
y será reasignado al siguiente elemento
de la lista y será 1 esto es lo que el
ciclo for hace cada vez que se ejecuta
hace que y sea igual a cada uno de los
elementos de la secuencia en orden y
ahora ejecutamos lo que hay dentro del
ciclo una vez más volvemos a ver lo que
vale producto y lo multiplicamos por 1
producto sigue valiendo 1 y ahora vale 1
así que uno más uno es 2 y 1 por 2 es el
nuevo valor de producto el nuevo valor
que reasignamos al producto es 2 ahora
será 2 el nuevo valor de la variable
producto es 2 entonces entramos en el
ciclo otra vez y en esta ocasión y
tendrá el valor del siguiente elemento y
será asignado al siguiente elemento en
la secuencia podemos decir también el
contenedor de la variable y es 2 y
trataremos de evaluar todo una vez más
producto ahora es 2
es 221 estrés así que esta expresión de
aquí este es tenemos dos producto vale 2
x y más 1 y es dos más uno es tres así
que dos por tres y seis el nuevo valor
del producto por y más uno es igual a
seis este producto ahora es igual a seis
y tratamos de ejecutar el ciclo otra vez
y el ciclo for dice ok voy a reasignar
un valor para y tiene que ser el
siguiente elemento de la secuencia y
trata de encontrar el siguiente elemento
en la secuencia pero dice esperen no hay
siguiente elemento en la secuencia así
que ya no es posible ejecutar el ciclo
for
el ciclo se rompe y salimos y
continuamos con la siguiente instrucción
del programa y la siguiente instrucción
literalmente es imprime producto print
producto en este punto lo que queremos
hacer es mostrar el valor del producto y
la variable producto vale 6 producto es
igual a 6 y lo que debía haber hecho
las revisamos el programa estuve
pensando sólo en la representación de
contenedores pero en esta representación
producto inicio refiriéndose a uno
después fue reasignado a uno después fue
reasignado a dos así que esta referencia
fue al 2 y luego fue reasignado a 6 fue
reasignado a 6 así que para ser
consistentes con esta representación
cada vez el producto fue reasignado a un
número diferente o ya saben podemos ver
las variables como contenedores de los
valores y lo que es padre de todo esto
es que el número que se encuentra en la
variable producto o podríamos decir el
número al que la variable producto hace
referencia es el factor y'all del número
que el usuario teclea al principio es el
factor y'all de 3 y si recuerdan 3 el
símbolo de factorial es el signo de
exclamación es igual a 3 por 2 por 1